كان عام
1979 فارقا في العلاقات بين مصر وايران
كانت العلاقه بارده لكنها منذ ذلك التاريخ
تحولت الى ناحيه العداء واستمرت على هذا
النحو منذ ذلك الوقت على مدى العقود
الماضيه بدايه اعمى
1979 اندلعت الثوره الايرانيه بقياده ايه
الله الخميني الرئيس المصري انذاك محمد
انور السادات كان موقفه واضحا استقبل
السادات وقتها شاه ايران محمد رضا بهلوي
الذي لجا الى مصر بعد رفض غالبيه الدول
ايواء
لكن في معركه لما بعثت لشائرا ام حول
المراكب من البحر تيجي على اسكندريه اللي
كانت رايحه اوروبا
حولها باللاسلكي على اسكندريه
[موسيقى]
وبعد مرور ثلاثه اشهر نحن في السادس
والعشرين من مارس 1979 وقعت مصر واسرائيل
اتفاقيه كاندي بدا لتقرر طهران وقتها قطع
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع مصر العام التالي
لم يكن مختلفا ارتفعت معه حده الخلافه بين
البلدين بسبب الحرب الايرانيه العراقيه
مصر رفضت الوقوف ضد بغداد ولان مواقف
السادات كانت مناهضه للخميني وبعد اغتيال
رئيس المصري عام
1981 اطلقت السلطات الايرانيه اسم المتهم
بقتله خالد الاسلامبولي على شارع في طهران
وما تسبب في استمرار الخلاف حتى الان
انيران وفي ايران كذلك وجدوا ذات الامر
ويرجع ذلك اساسا الى ان الخميني تعرض
لمعامله سيئه للغايه في العراق قبل
مغادرته فرنسا وارسله صدام حسين الى فرنسا
بناء على طلب شاه ايران
العداء والقطيعه الطويله قد تكون في
طريقها للزوال فخلال الاشهر الماضيه ظهرت
اشارات ايجابيه بين القاهره وطهران وزير
الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري التقى نائب
الرئيس الايراني علي سلاجقه في نوفمبر
الماضي على هامش مؤتمر المناخ كب 27 في
شرم الشيخ وفي الشهر التالي التقى الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي بوزير الخارجيه
الايراني حسين امير عبد اللهيان وذلك على
هامشي مؤتمر بغداد اثنين الذي اقيم في
الاردن
وتوالى بعدها عدد من التصريحات لمسؤولين
ايرانيين اشاروا الانفتاح طهران على
مفاوضات عوده العلاقات مع مصر حسين امير
مثلا
حسنا اولا وقبل كل شيء هناك مكاتب حمايه
مصالح البلدين في طهران والقاهره وعلى راس
هذه المكاتب من الجانبين هناك شخص على
مستوى سفير لذلك توجد قناه رسميه للتواصل
والاتصال بيننا مباشره بالطبع بذلت بعض
الدول بعض الجهود لتشجيع مصر وحتى جمهوريه
ايران الاسلاميه على رفع مستوى العلاقات
بين البلدين
اذا هناك دول تحاول التوسط بين مصر وايران
عمان الوسيط الاول فمسقط تربطها علاقه
وثيقه مع ايران وهي من توسطت بين طهران
والدول الكبرى في الاتفاق النووي عام 2015
في يوليو من العام الماضي افاد موقع ان
كبير المفوضين الايرانيين علي باقر زار
سلطنه عمان وناقش فكره الاتصالات بين
طهران والقاهره وقبل اسبوع زار سلطان عمان
هيثم بن طارق القاهره وكانت الزياره
الاولى له الى مصر منذ توليه المنصب قبل
اكثر من ثلاث سنوات ثم بعدها بايام زار
طهران والتقى بالمرشد الايراني علي خامني
الذي رحب خلال اللقاء باستئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه مع القاهره
جريمه
بعد تصريحات المرشد الاعلى امر الرئيس
وزاره الخارجيه باتخاذ التدابير اللازمه
لتوطيد وتطوير العلاقات ان شاء الله
العراق الوسيط الثاني رئيس وزرائها محمد
شياع السوداني اقترح اطلاق حوارا مصريا
ايراني في ديسمبر الماضي وهو مرحبا به
وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين امير
تقارير عده ومنها ما نشر على صحيفه
عراقي اكد عقد جوله محادثات في العراق
لبحث القضايا العالقه لكن رسميا الطرفيا
رغم ذلك نقلت وكاله مهر الايرانيه عن عضو
لجنه الامن القومي والسياسه الخارجيه في
البرلمان الايراني في دحسين مالكي تاكيده
ان جوله محادثات جرت بالفعل
وفقا لوجهه نظر حكومه الدكتور الرئيسي ان
يتم تطوير العلاقات مع دول المنطقه ومع
مصر الشقيقه والصديقه كما نعطي الاولويه
للعلاقات مع هذا البلد في السياسه
الخارجيه لنشهد انفتاحا وكي تكون هناك
خطوات جديده ومتبادله
يعني طبعا السياسات بتنتهك والسياسات فيها
توسع
ومحاوله فرض نفوذ وهيمنه في النطاق العربي
والتاثير على الاوضاع في الدول العربيه
شيء غير مقبول من قبل مصر ودائما كانت مصر
واضحه في ذلك نحن نرى دائما العلاقات يجب
ان تبنى على فكره الاحترام المتبادل وعدم
التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه وعدم التامر
وانما العمل في اطار المصالح المشتركه
بعيدا عن فكره الهيمنه او النفوس عندما
تقدر ايران بان هذا هو المسلك الصحيح هذا
يغير من
الحاله الحاليه التي نشهدها
بشان النقاط العالقه طالب الطهران بعقد
اجتماع امني سياسي مع القاهره يتم تحديده
خلال الفتره المقبله تسعى طهران لمعرفه
مطالب القاهره بشكل اكبر ولذلك تريد
اجتماعات مباشره وتشكيل لجنه من الطرفين
تكون وظيفتها وضع صيغه لاعاده العلاقات
ووضع البنود التي يتم الاتفاق عليها ورغم
ان القاهره نفط رسميا على لسان وزير
خارجيتها ما تردد عن وجود مسار مصري
ايراني لتطوير العلاقات لكن القاهره
منفتحه على الاشارات الايرانيه الايجابيه
لتطوير العلاقات واحدى هذه الاشارات جاءت
قبل ايام على لسان وزير الخارجيه الايراني
بالقاهره
ان موقف السيد السيسي من تطورات السنوات
الاخيره في المنطقه وخاصه محاربه داعش
والتطرف في حاله سوريا كان موقفا منطقيا
وصحيحا اشارات ايجابيه من طيران قابلتها
اخرى من القاهره وتحديدا في مارس الماضي
وفي ملف السياحه
[موسيقى]
هناك امور قد تعيق هذا التقدم في
المحادثات اسرائيل في الصوره صحيفه يدعو
تحرنوط الاسرائيليه اشارت الى ان حكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو ابلغت القاهره باستيائها
البالغ مما يتردد حول حدوث تطورات ايجابيه
في العلاقات بين القاهره والطيران ورغم
الخلافات الحاده بين الحكومه الاسرائيليه
والمعارضه وسنتناول ذلك بالتفصيل بعد قليل
لكنهما في هذا الملف متفقا التقارب المصري
الايراني يتعارض مع المصالح الاسرائيليه
والاقليميه بحسب زعيم المعارضه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات